most of us have grown up watching Disney
Princesses but how much do you really
know about these beloved characters if
you're new to our channel hit the button
down below to subscribe and watch this
video to discover it soon surprising
things you didn't know about Disney
Princesses snow white snow white is the
youngest inattentive of just 14 she's
the only one to have a Hollywood Walk of
Fame star more than 150 girls audition
to provide her voice but adriana
caselotti gutted by chance for some en
coche father help disney choose an aid
rihanna overheard their phone call she
talked in the background to show she had
the perfect voice for the part
Jasmine Jasmine does a lot of spicy
things in Aladdin like sneaking out of
the palace and helping to teach afar but
she is actually only 15 that makes her
the second hand of Disney Princess she's
also the only Disney princess from
locked lips to the villain when chickens
Jafar fell you might have noticed Belle
has a little wisp of hair that keeps
falling in her face screenplay writer
Linda Woolverton grows eyepieces written
script because she wanted belt not be
perfect
Belle was partly inspired by Katharine
Hepburn's fiction of gel in Little Women
Cinderella Cinderella was Walt Disney's
favorite heroine she says Eileen woods
actress voiced her there's something
about that story I associate with and
wealth also said the transformation
scene where she goes from rags to a ball
gown with one of his all-time favorite
bits of animation Aurora Aurora is
unique amongst Disney Princesses she's
the only one the silent eyes she's also
the quietest of them all having only 18
lines of dialogue in 18 minutes of
screen time flora and Merryweather
squabble over the color of her dress
based on a real wardrobe disagreement
Ariel Sherri stoner Ariel's live-action
model inspired lots of the character's
mannerisms
she was also Belle's live-action
reference but it was Alyssa Milano who
inspired Ariel face her red hair is
thanks to / it we didn't want Ariel
having blond hair like the mermaid in
that movie Rapunzel we all know Rapunzel
has the longest hair but do you know how
long it's 70 feet long and has
hundred thousand strands she also has
the biggest eyes out of all the Disney
Princesses before Mandy Moore voice
Kristin Chenoweth and Reese Witherspoon
were cast but both dropped out Merida
Reese Witherspoon also dropped out of
voicing Merida
Kelly Macdonald got the part and that
made Merida the only Disney Princess to
not have an American accent and talking
of hair if Meredith curls were
straightened her locks would reach her
calves and be four feet long Pocahontas
out of all the Disney Princesses also
Pocahontas is based on a real person
she's 18 in the film but in real life
she met John Smith when she was much
younger Pocahontas and Anna from frozen
are the only princesses to have to love
interest Pocahontas is our cocoon and
John Mulan like Pocahontas Mulan does
not marry a friend Milan is based on the
ancient Chinese legend a female warrior
for Mulan there's no proof she existed
in real life in the Ballad of Mulan poem
Quran doesn't reveal her true gender
until after the war Mulan and Jasmine
are the only busy princesses who wear
pen Lea Salonga performs both of their
singing voices - Tiana Tiana is more
relatable than the other Disney
Princesses in one major way she's the
only one to have an official job and a
normal one at that being a waitress
she's also the only Disney princess to
have dimples she's left-handed - but she
shares that in common with Mulan Elsa
Elsa is the oldest Disney Princess at 21
all the rest are teenagers if you want
to know how else was feeling just look
at the color of her ice palace when she
sided purple when she's scared a thread
when she's happy blue and when she's
angry it's yellow Anna Anna no kahan
tests are the only two Disney Princesses
to have more than one love interest
Anna's are Hans and Kristoff and her
song which hand love is an open door
makes Anna the only Disney Princess was
a duet with a villain Elena
TVs Elena of avalor Disney's first
Latina princess she was created because
of social media backlash when Disney's
other TV princess Sofia the first was
falsely reported as being a Latina
princess she's not the show's creator
said the reaction showed that there was
a demand for a Latina princess and the
lemon was born at 16 she's the same age
as Aurora Ariel and Mulan Moana
like Elena sixteen-year-old Moana has
love interest Disney's first Polynesian
princess has also deliberately designed
with a realistic body type her name
means ocean in the South Pacific and
economic gendered names director John
Musker says Mulan is the most similar of
all the Disney Princesses to this new
edition but Moana is more extreme which
of these 15 things about Disney
Princesses did you find most interesting
let us know in the comments below and
don't forget to give our video a big
thumbs up
you